[Music]
2020 is shaping up to be a record year
for betting on stock options
on an average day traders drew up more
than 26 million
such contracts a huge rise from the year
before
nine out of ten of the busiest days in
the options market's
entire history going back to 1973
have happened this year in 2020
option contracts give traders a way to
make a buck by
betting on which way the markets will
swing which makes them especially
attractive
when markets are choppy like they've
been this year but there's a catch
options are a risky investment sometimes
even riskier than stocks
and as more beginners try their hand at
trading experts warn of big losses
[Music]
at its most basic level an option is a
contractual agreement between two
parties regarding a particular asset
say a stock and there are two basic
types
calls and puts with a call option
the buyer gets the right to purchase
shares at an agreed upon price
and date if the trader doesn't buy the
shares in that window
she loses the right to buy the shares at
that price
and that's an important feature of these
options contracts you don't have to
exercise them you simply have the option
to do so
within a specific time frame when a
trader buys calls
they're typically making a bet that the
asset will rise in value
if it does she can profit
let's walk through an example shares of
a company are trading at 100
on the day the option contract is bought
a trader secures the option to purchase
100 shares
at 120 dollars each at some point for
the next
month in this scenario 120
is the strike price the trader that buys
the contract
thinks the stock will rise so she pays a
premium
of three dollars per share or for this
contract
300 total many investors are using these
options
contracts as trading tools and often
they don't even have an intention
to exercise them for example if you buy
an auction
and the contract itself rises in value
you might sell that option contract in
the secondary market
in this case the call holder is using
the option contract as a trading tool
not dealing with the underlying shares
but this type of trading can get
complicated
sometimes it's not as simple and that's
because there's a lot of different
inputs
to options pricing that includes the
strike price
that that you're buying the option for
the time to expiration
and also the implied volatility or how
much
the stock is expected to swing up or
down in the future
the option buyer has other ways to
profit as well if the share value rises
higher
than the strike price and the premium
paid the buyer can
exercise the contract in this example
say the share price rises to 135 dollars
which is above the strike price and
premium
combined the call holder can buy the
stocks for 120 dollars
and sell it on the market for 135
dollars
pocketing the difference but let's say
the shares price never rises above 123
dollars
in this case the contract holder doesn't
have to buy the stock
she can toss the contract in the trash
and walk away having only lost the
premium of three dollars per share
but this is where it gets risky for
amateurs these losses can add up quickly
options can seem like a relatively
cheaper way
to sometimes bet on expensive stocks but
you know if if your hunch is wrong a few
times
that can be several hundred dollars at a
time just kind of going down the drain
and potentially burning a hole in your
portfolio you know you may think oh i
just need to put down
200 or 300 for this options premium
and if the stock does this i'll be right
and i can make a quick 40
return but if you're wrong a few times
that's a lot of money for a lot of
people and this happens frequently
many options go unexercised now the
other kind of options trade
is a put in a put contract a trader who
owns a stock
is buying the right to sell that asset
to someone else for a particular price
by a particular date a trader might buy
a put
if they think the stock will fall or if
they want to hedge
their holdings similar to a call option
the trader has the choice to sell
or walk away from the deal and lose the
premium
people often use put options to
bet on stock declines or hedge their
portfolios kind of like a stock
insurance so
a portfolio manager could use a put
option to
you know protect a portfolio from bigger
declines in the s p 500
or something like that so those are the
fundamentals
now here's why options are popular
investors
like options partly because the premium
can let an investor
control more assets than they otherwise
could afford they can be kind of a
cheaper way
to bet on you know somewhat expensive
stocks
for example amazon you know has been
recently trading
around thirty one hundred dollars a
share
meanwhile you could buy an option
contract typed amazon
which technically gives you control over
a hundred shares of amazon
for a few hundred dollars another reason
why options are popular this year
big swings give investors more chances
to bet
the pandemic and election have led to
huge fluctuations in stock prices
which has given traders more
opportunities to bet using option
contracts
another reason people at home have more
time on their hands
and are trading frequently recently
small trades of a single contract
made up 8.7 percent of all options
activity
according to trade alert data those
traders are taking a risk
because making the right call or put is
difficult if not impossible
even for the most advanced traders not
to mention the fees and capital gains
taxes
which can eat into your profits it can
be really tempting to make these short
term relatively cheap bets on where
individual stocks
or the market will go but it's really
hard to figure out what the stock market
is going to do next and
if you guess a few times wrong you could
be out a lot of money
for a smaller investor that means that
consistent success
trading options is tricky regardless
traders are free to swim in the choppy
waters
if they wish
[Music]
you